the Los Angeles Lakers are back in the
conference semifinals for the first time
since their Championship run in 2020
with the king in the Browns the only
remaining cast members they were the
first seed then a seventh seed now and
the urgency to seize the opportunities
equivalent that's just how it goes in
the land of purple and gold however
seating has shown to me very little in
this year's playoffs simply put you need
to be playing your best basketball right
now the Lakers were not for most of the
year as they made it over 500 in the
77th game of the season LeBron's career
scoring title was a nice moment but
what's left the Darwin ham hire became a
lamenting discussion amongst the lake
show LeBron looked dejected on most
nights the best shooter in the building
appeared at halftime and a play-in
tournament appearance seemed far-fetched
at one point this Laker season was
strictly for blooper real purposes and
embarrassment the most popular kid in
school was indeed a loser that helps you
understand what I'm saying the trade
deadline reinvigorated this ball Club
adding complementary pieces that helped
them enter the postseason ranked top 10
in defensive rating in the final 10
games of the season the wing depth
versatility and play making have shifted
the course of the season the scoring low
now looks adequately spread across the
team a young Supporting Cast with little
playoff experience has been asked to
step up their level of play and so far
they've answered the Bell now they turn
their attention to the Splash Brothers
and Company who just overcame a 2-0
deficit and appeared to be rounding into
form a meeting between familiar foes and
Hall of Fame resumes longer than a Sam's
Club receipt the two best players of the
decade are set to share the floor again
for the Lakers their confidence and
continuity appear to grow by The Game
and further distance the memories of how
they once looked they have won in many
Fashions and must lean on those
experiences versus a tested group in the
Champs the Lakers salvaged would look
like a lost cause and now are legit
contenders momentum is one hell of a
wave to ride and right now that's their
best friend